*sad trombone*
Looks like somebody has a case of the mondays
*Music*
quick-
quick playthrough the Epic High-five animation
I'm adding more and more frames to my animatic so it's looking more and more like animation, not just
storyboards it's more to get an idea, what needs more frames just kind of get a feeling for timing
Yeah, I really thought I was gonna be like 30 seconds already, but it's only like five seconds
It's slowly coming together, but I'm hoping I can get it done by Friday
should be interesting.. I'm actually having a lot of fun with it, but I'm a little nervous. I'm hoping it comes out good
Hey Ned
You missed a spot there
*sweeping intensifies*
So you guys might notice there was a little white dot in that hololens animation
that we made the action gram animation
the way the Headset works is a little cursor right in the center of your field of view and you can record just what you see
and have it sent to your computer, you can also make specific recordings that don't have it, anyways we messed up
and we did the recording that just captures everything including your cursor, so try to ignore that white dot just imagine
It's aaaaa.. it's a really tiny dinosaur
I've got a new challenge. Get as close to the gopro as physically possible
hit the gopro
*thwack*
*laughter, potentially that of a snake*
Now you see the Wren, in its natural habitat
On weekdays he will do VFX and wrender at the end of his compositing.
I hate you so much right now
*laughter*
He will loathe and disdain onlookers when he takes his resting naps
It appears that nature has won.
cycle of life continues.
It's all your fault Peter
It's all your fault
IT'S ALL YOUR FAULT - everyone in the comments is correctly guessing that the source of all of our problems is Peter
Is that a thing?
But in the first video they loved me
Yeah, not anymore
I've only touched this computer. And that computer. And that computer.
And that computer. And that computer. And that computer.
*laughter*
uhh
I do my best
It's close.
What are these other holes by the way? Here's another arrow hole
didn't dent the tip at all though which is nice. We still need to do The Gopro Challenge
Where you start with an arrow far from it and each  arrow has to be consecutively closer to it
An arrow in the bottom circle.. and I'm gonna work my way up
*thwack (x1)*
*thwack (x2)*
*thwack (x3)*
There we go. That's pretty close
That's my first one. Give myself some distance. That's my second, close the distance a little too much. This is my third...
There's no way I was getting an arrow any closer to the gopro than that.. and that's my fourth and my fifth
GoPro Challenge, technically a failure
Super cool. Probably going to be asking for a lot of stuff when Thether gets going
So just helping with concepts and art and all that kind of stuff. Yeah, I'm so down all that stuff
Um the hardest part about drawing storyboards is drawing the boxes
yeah, surprisingly it is not as easy they start off pretty nice and then it's *furious hand movements* nasty
What a clusterfunk. What are you guys talking about? The Movie.
We don't know what's going on at this point number wise budget wise for the effects
just like you need to tell us exactly how many shots we can have. Can't have as many VFX shots. Just went in and
Figured out what VFX shots we could cut think we tried to do so much stuff
Practically makes all the difference in the world talk to them like is this enough VFX shots what you know you guys got to figure
out things like camera shakes, warp stabilization, some atmosphere stuff like we just add a
Overlay in front of the camera like does that count as VFX how many of those can we do? So we sat down and figured out
what we're going to cut and where and what's going to change not much is changing thankfully
Basically we called it a day without finishing the editing, but we went through and gave notes and stuff to the editor
Now Sam and I are like stressed but very very level-headed and focused right now here like if there's a problem we need to solve
We will solve it
Like, if this is real, you gotta commit to it being real you can't half commit to it being real and that's my biggest issue right now.
How crazy is it to delay it one more extra week?
*BOOM*